Carter speaking a hall of famers look at  Carter again [ __ ] Carter  but you can see the tabs very veteran  team really working for their open looks  Carter speaking the veteran in the first  half  [Applause]  [Music]  now they repost Vince look if it's  harder it may have just raised the iron  but it doesn't matter it's Jean Paul  Carter  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  it's Carter Carter turn the sprinkler  system time Vince Carter is on fire  file didn't get one there 101 89  quarterbacks in a half Korver  all the powers in the scores are you  sure he's 40 years old  no surprise there Vince Carter he has  been outstanding in this game  Carter little shake and bake  Jae Crowder just shaking his hand like